the Godzilla franchise is recognized by  Guinness World Records to be the longest  continuously running movie franchise  having been an ongoing production from  1954 to the present day with several  hiatus of varying lengths the film  franchise consists of 35 films telugu  produced by Toho  and three Hollywood films there are  almost 30 2009 suits and CGI body frames  of different than unique styles some  designs were used continuously for two  to three films in sequence while others  are totally new and even we are led to  try Susilo let's take a look at a size  comparison of all these Godzilla  incarnations two at a time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]